[Musique]
les marins du ciel par et à
l'affrontement les vins rafale du porte
avions charles de gaulle prennent part à
une bataille aéronaval fictive en
méditerranée
deux camps des moyens symétrique pour
une confrontation crédible la force
rouge commandait depuis un
porte-hélicoptères amphibie est engagée
contre la bleue celle du porte avions
pour ce pilote de chasse embarqués sur
le charles de gaulle un combat de haute
intensité c'est très concret on
l'assimilé une action diplomatique
une action
le coordination de nos moyens aériens et
est souvent c'est envisagé comme des
frappes des frappes de sidération des
frappes fulgurantes tu vois très
concentrée dans le temps on va avoir la
totalité des missiles qui va arriver
dans une période très courte et qui va
venir du coup avoir un effet militaire
décisive en ennemi furtif un réalisme
poussé à l'extrême l'entraînement vise à
déstabiliser les militaires à développer
leur agilité tactique face aux imprévus
comme des pannes de satellites touchés
et presque coulé fin de partie pour les
frégates bombardé des deux camps la
force rouge en a perdu une malgré le
coup dur sa riposte est de taille
et tactique un peu
[Musique]
disruptive commandites c'est à dire que
l été en mesure de nous surprendre en
notamment et bien en sachant se diluer
disparaître échapper tantôt à nos ânes
haute surveillance à nos radars et pour
venir essayer de nous surprendre et
essayer de nous empêcher d'avoir l'accès
à cette zone de frappe la
synchronisation parfaite c'est la
mission des chiens jaunes
ces opérateurs qui catapulte les rafales
depuis le pont d'envol 30 départ
d'avions de chasse groupe et par jour
contre 12 habituellement la cadence
s'intensifie et tout se joue à la mini
seconde près
on va voir des pontes et enchaîner donc
on récupère des avions pour les re
catapulte et ainsi de suite on peut
avoir des alertes c'est à dire des
avions qui sont sur le pont avec le
pilote dans l'avion mais qui ne décolle
que plus tard donc pour nous la
difficulté ça va être ça ça va être
d'anticiper mais pas trop non plus
d'être prêt à se reconfigurer
65 avions et hélicoptères 25 navires des
pavillons britanniques américains et
européens des frégates de combat l'élite
tes marines de l'otan la france veut
garder l'initiative alors que les maires
se re militarise la chine est lancé dans
la course sa marine dépasse celle de l'
us navy en nombre de bâtiments et pékin
construit l'équivalent de la flotte
française tous les trois ans les
contextes d'intimidation se multiplient
dans la région indo pacifique ou en mer
noire et élargissent les risques de
conflits aujourd'hui on voit qu'un
combat naval c'est un combat spatial un
combat sous marin un combat cyber un
combat informationnelle et donc
aujourd'hui on a touché du doigt la
nécessité d'avoir des boucles de
connexion entre tous ces domaines qu'ils
soient beaucoup plus rapide où trouver
la frégate qui est là bas je n'ai pas
uniquement envoyer un avion de
patrouille maritime ou une phase
satellite et je veux aussi chercher sur
twitter
je vais aussi chercher son tik tok et on
trouve et donc c'est aujourd'hui sous
les la guerre même au niveau tactique et
technique complètement composite la
guerre de demain on la connaît pas ce
qui est certain c'est qu'on a ouvert la
boîte permettant à nos marins de se dire
que la gare de demain n'étant pas écrite
il faudra la montée pour faire face à
ces nouvelles réalités il faut
s'entraîner ensemble cinq pays alliés se
sont portés volontaires pour participer
à polaris 21 comme le royaume-uni
intéressé par l'innovation de défense
développer dans les états major français
un milliard d'euros par an est dédié à
ce secteur c'est deux fois plus qu'en
l'environnement et le terrain de
l'exercice tout comme sa conception
c'est une véritable opportunité
d'entraînement bien sûr il y aura
toujours un aspect artificiel dans tout
exercice
mais ici avec la dimension imprévisible
des menaces et la façon dont cela a été
géré durant l'exercice c'est vraiment
utile
la marine nationale est la royal navy
sont similaires en bien des aspects par
leur taille et leur zone d'opération et
elles sont toutes les deux membres de
l'auteur
quarante deux mille tonnes de diplomatie
armée c'est la façon dont les officiers
américains désignent le charles de
gaulle véritable base aérienne flottante
capable de se déplacer de mille
kilomètres par jour pendant des mois et
d'assurer l'autonomie stratégique de la
france grâce à ces sous-marins
nucléaires d'attaqué mais la frontière
semble de plus en plus mince entre
dissuasion et actions alors que le droit
international est régulièrement bafoués
sur et sous les océans